Peter King NBC sports.com and of course
is great column football morning in
America Peter joins us now Peter what
kind of elements do you think will take
out of this virtual draft that will
implement maybe next year in Cleveland
dan I wouldn't be surprised to see the
NFL still use a lot of draftees in their
homes maybe bring fewer big stars to
Cleveland and and and instead of
bringing instead of having all of the
stars come to Cleveland I think there's
a really good chance that they sort of
merged the two ideas you know whatever
Trevor Lawrence you know chest-bumping
with Roger Goodell and then maybe all
the guys beyond pick 25 or whatever you
see that drama at home like to me the
two things out of this draft that people
will never forget is an in look I had I
had five general managers between
Saturday and Sunday who you know two of
whom really did not like this okay
entering you know two weeks ago even
mickey loomis who didn't like it told me
that it's a memory as kids will never
forget and and and you know to have so
many you know key NFL people have their
kids draped on them when they're making
the picks I mean it probably will never
happen again but you know what Dan maybe
it should whose team's strategy do you
have a hard time wrapping your head
around right now uh well I mean I didn't
love the Packers but not necessarily for
their Jordan love reason I didn't love
the Packers because whatever you think
of the future of Aaron Rodgers you know
let's leave that to the side Dan in the
last six this is a second draft in a row
where they didn't take a wide receiver
okay
it is the sixth draft in a row where
they did not take a wide receiver in the
first three rounds and in all six of
those seasons they did not spend three
agent money on a big wide receiver so
they basically are doing to Aaron
Rodgers in my opinion what Bill
Belichick did to Tom Brady last year
saying hey listen you're a great player
win it you and Josh McDaniels go figure
it out and you know to me this is about
a franchise that in my opinion the game
is changing you need explosion look at
what the Denver Broncos are doing look
at their receiving core it's utterly
fantastic and that is the way the game
is going right now the Kansas City
Chiefs are providing a blueprint for
everybody yeah I'm with you on that
trying to understand this they the
reason why I don't like the Jordan Love
pick more than anything is I have I got
the the financial aspect of this with
Aaron Rodgers he's tied up for four
years and you want that rookie contract
at the quarterbacking position all of
these teams that you know went and golf
and Baker Mayfield I mean all these
daniel Jones they're all put in there to
start so they can take advantage of that
contract by the time Jordan Love gets
ready to play if he does get ready to
play in Green Bay it might be four years
down the road you're not able to take
advantage of that rookie contract I
think Jordan loves got a decent chance
to be the next Garoppolo and you know if
you look at the way this could go let's
say Aaron Rodgers sort of used this just
like Brett Favre did quite honestly as
I'll show them you know and and and
let's say he views it is that when he
reports whenever this season is played
if it is you know I think what's gonna
happen is you're gonna see that unless
Rodgers gets hurt I think it's gonna be
very hard for him to come off the field
in the next three years
I talked to GM Brian gudykunst yesterday
and I asked him that same question this
guy
I mean Rodgers told me a year and a half
ago he wants to play at least 40 of his
legs are sound and and and so that's
four more years then and if he placed
four more years
however the Packers gonna be able to
know whether they should exercise that
50-year option and I asked that to go to
consider he said
if Aaron plays great for the next four
years essentially and I'm paraphrasing
him that would be great for the Packers
yeah but Pete I would rather have a
motivated Aaron Rodgers with some wide
receivers you know what I'll tell you
what if I take Jordan love right there
you know what I do I trade a lot a lot
to move up either high in the second
round or even back up low in the first
even if it means next year's one I trade
a lot to get my nickel Pittman or T
Higgins or whoever you know I if the
Packers are a very smart personnel team
I would trust them to look at their
draft board in the greatest year for
wide receivers in the draft maybe ever
but I think they've got to come out of
this draft with one this year your uh
favorite team in the draft pardon me
that's Chuck the dog he must hear
somebody at the door again
my favorite team yeah I'll say - I'm
gonna give you two quick ones number one
San Francisco because John Lynch gets
thrown this hand grenade hey by the way
Joe Staley all-decade player he's not
playing this year not only does he need
a defensive tackle and a wide receiver
in this draft he now needs a you know an
often a left tackle so he makes the
trade for Trent Williams and he gets
obviously he gets Kinlaw as the
defensive tackle and they love Brandon
Iook so they draft him so I really like
what they did and and look it's a little
bit selfish but I think what the Bucs
did was really cool first of all Tampa
Bay general manager Jason light let me
into his virtual drafter him and I
witnessed their first round and they
chased and chased and chased and finally
got the right tackle for Tom Brady you
know Tristan worse the most interesting
thing about that Dan when I witnessed
that technology helped them do their
jobs they were not detoured from doing
anything because they all weren't in the
same driver yeah I wondered about that I
felt
because we had had some analysts who
were you know they were projecting there
be a lot of trades in the first round
and then I wondered if because of the
technology because of how the draft was
a virtual draft that would make it
harder to pull off these deals you're
saying that that wasn't the case with
Tampa I don't think it was now there
were last year there were 41 trades in
the draft this year there were 33 so
maybe some teams were a little spooked
by it but I can tell you that you know
that that Jason light the GM of the Bucs
or his personnel guys called every team
after from from seven and beyond and
tried to get that pick because they were
all set in they were focused in on
getting a right tackle for Tom Brady and
that was Tristen worse they thought he
was the best right tackle in the draft
so every time they called it wasn't
because there wasn't enough time on the
clock or it was awkward or anything like
that they had plenty of time they never
came close now when they finally
reported the pick there was only 45
seconds left but so what that's that's
plenty of time to get a pick in he's
Peter King NBC sports.com and the column
is football morning in America Jalen
Hurd's being selected says more about
Carson Wentz or trying to find the next
Taysom Hill I would say neither
I'd say neither in my opinion that is
simply a recognition of the fact that on
some teams when you don't have a solid
rock 16 game every year starter and
Carson Wentz's missed seven games one
year six games the next year in 17 and
18 so he's not been a solid rock maybe
he'll try to turn out to be phil simms
i'll after a lot of injuries early he
becomes that solid rock guy he isn't
right now this is about on a team like
Philadelphia the backup quarterback is
not the same for every team but the
backup quarterback on the Philadelphia
Eagles is one of the ten most important
people on the team that's a fact if you
don't have a good backup quarterback and
your quarterback gets hurt
you're seized
/ so Nick for having Nick Foles was a
huge boon to them in seventeen and
eighteen he won him a Super Bowl and
they didn't have that unless you think
that you know untested backups
you know like kya hua Letta are gonna be
really good but you don't know that
that's why to me getting hurts as a
smart move for the Eagles when you look
at camps being opened up like what has
to happen between now and whatever that
date is before you know if the NBA comes
back is that gonna help out with the I
know there's far more players with the
NFL but what kind of you know
precautions are gonna have to be put in
place before you can have actually have
teams get together one of the toughest
things for the NFL whenever the NFL
starts whether it be training camp
practice whatever is you know are they
going to feel good about taking all of
these tests from somewhere when America
is crying out when the doctors and
governors and mayors say we want to do
more testing what's it gonna be like if
every week every NFL team let's just say
uses 500 tests to make sure that they
can keep the Train on the tracks and
keep going and that's just a wild guess
I would think that they'd have to test
their players all their players and and
important staff once or twice a week at
least and so are they gonna be
comfortable in taking thousands of tests
from training camp and into the regular
season away from the larger populous
yeah I think we got a long road here
certainly with that but I could see
where they hoarders the quarterbacks all
get together you could have a you know a
virtual quarterback room where you could
actually have these Joe burrow could get
together with his quarterback coach or
the offensive coordinator I don't know
if Andy Dalton's still in the mix there
by the way Andy Dalton and Cam Newton
now more likely to find a home with the
draft being over are we gonna have to
wait until close you know so you mean
you know there's still a problem with
Cam Newton you know teams want to they
want to meet him up front
they want to get there have their
doctors be able to get their hands on
them so I those are that's to me
unanswerable right now adult is a
different story he doesn't have an
injury history you know so but but who
knows but the one thing about your prior
point then you know I asked Zack Taylor
because I talked to him over the weekend
and I talked to borough uh you know how
weird will it be if you know if this
let's say the season starts on October
first and how weird would it be if Joe
borough meets AJ Green on Labor Day
weekend if he meets T Higgins uh you
know Tyler boy if he meets all of his
guys who's he's gonna have to you know
sing beautiful music with but but I'll
just say this for all the people who say
well he won't play this year they better
play any dog I mean maybe they will but
I will also say this Russell Wilson
nineteen days after he practiced for the
first time with Wisconsin and whatever
year that was 2011 I think it was you
know he's playing football games of
winning big ten games for them Cam
Newton didn't have an off season program
with the Carolina Panthers practiced for
five and a half weeks and then threw for
four hundred yards in his first game
it's not impossible all I'm saying is
that it's gonna be weird and also Dan
how about this Joe burrow you know Ohio
Joe burrow cannot work out at Athens
high school his high school alma mater
his dad coach at Ohio University he
can't work out there either so he's
gonna have to work out Zach at just a
field maybe even in his backyard you
know outside of Athens he's gonna have
to find a field to throw to and then
Zach Taylor I'm not sure he was kidding
he said hey he might have to work with
his mom and dad it's just it's a I mean
Dan this I I find this one of the most
interesting times maybe the most
interesting time of my sports writing
career because there is so much
happening they if if you
told me that you were going to be
watching the Tampa Bay Buccaneers 1st
round of the draft on your on my iPhone
from a from an iPad put in the room and
that's gonna be the huge thing in your
post traffic
that's insane it's just it and so that's
the kind of stuff that I just find so
incredibly interesting right now well
there's nothing going on but there's
everything going on yes right that's an
excellent way to put it
Pete great to talk to you a great column
as well great insights we appreciate
your time and say goodbye to chuck for
all right hey Chuck Dan says goodbye
does he bark on cue
no he just barks if he hears the
slightest noise just Chuck do any tricks
Peter yes he begs very well yeah but I
don't really love it here in the King
household yeah but I've been to dinner
with you Pete you do the same thing
[Laughter]
thank you Peter that's Peter King Peter
King NBC sports.com the football morning
in America column